an hour and a half from Rome the villas
hidden behind these high walls and
hedges our vacation homes for well-off
Italians but there's also a shadow side
to this fertile region the produce grown
here is sold in supermarkets throughout
Europe but the laborers who harvest the
fruits and vegetables earn only a few
euros per hour some of them have come
from as far away as India Chuck Jeet
Singh has been working in latina for 12
years
he's one of nearly 18,000 Sikhs from
Punjab working in this region friends
from his village back home had told him
he could earn good money in Italy's
agriculture sector
he knew life here wouldn't be easy but
he found it so challenging at the
beginning that he often considered
returning to India I pawned gold jewelry
belonged to my wife and sister to pay
for the trip here I thought I'd earn the
money back quickly and retrieve the
jewelry but to pay off the loan we had
to sell the gold instead almost everyone
who comes here goes through the same
thing is very different from what we
expected
goodbye George ski helmet an intricate
thing I would be beside me alter the
living and working conditions are
miserable
the official minimum wage is about 9
euros the farmers pay less than a third
of that many Indians work seven days a
week during harvest time up to 12 to 13
hours a day we were free in India I had
my own business I could come to work
late and go home early if I had better
things to do here is different here
you're only paid for the air as you work
but I'm doing better than others
Ajit Singh has paid off his debts so he
no longer has to share a small flat with
four or five other workers as he did
before most are too afraid to speak on
camera investigators say the laborers
are trapped in their illegal jobs at the
mercy of criminal gangs the majority of
them have paid thousands of euros to
people smugglers in exchange for forged
papers and passage to Italy as a result
many end up as bonded laborers who need
years to get out of debt analysts say
this practice is widespread throughout
Italy the farm workers take drugs like
amphetamines opium and muscle relaxants
especially at the beginning to cope with
the punishing work conditions OPI antes
pasty she can't imagine being bent over
picking radishes for 14 hours a day with
the boss standing over you saying work
work kenapa drawing account of initial
Evora Evora Evora your body and soul
would burn out pretty fast investigators
say the racket involves middlemen who
seek out laborers then keep part of
their wages and dictate their work hours
all of which is illegal in Italy and
there's hardly a business in the
agricultural sector that isn't part of
this system one of the biggest radish
producers in Europe allowed us to film
on their premises we confront the head
of the company with the allegations
about the middlemen and the exploitation
of their workers none of that's true
that contradicts our company philosophy
if we found anyone was doing this we
would fire them and we are not among the
firms that exploit their workers seek
important or non proper benefit so it
even then the union workers insist that
this company also pays its labourers
below the minimum wage and that
middlemen are active there too it's one
person's word against another the
workers themselves weren't comment they
want to keep their jobs
chef Keith Singh was able to bring his
wife and children to Italy a few
so go in the evenings other laborers
come for dinner including men who've
lived here for years in the hope of
bringing their own families here despite
the difficulties they say they're
determined to stay because the money
they earn in Italy is still far more
than what they'd be paid in India